good morning everybody
and welcome to the mid suffolk district
council licensing and regulatory
committee
today the 2nd of october my name is
kathy guthrie and i'm the chairman today
now first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones and
videos are muted and turned off when you
are not speaking
that you do not interrupt the other
speakers members are reminded not to use
the messaging
chat function during the meeting
i'm going to quite brave here we're
going to try and use the hands up
function
on everything except for a roll call so
we'll do that
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions
or we will do the hands-up function so
we will await your turn
if you experience connection issues in
the first instance please turn off your
camera
if the does not work you can turn off
all incoming video
these options are available under the
three dots in the main information bar
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering the meeting as a speaker you
are also consented
to being recorded by the council and
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting
and all training purposes the council
members of the public and press may
record film or photograph or broadcast
the meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
so the introductions are case our case
sanders unfortunately isn't with us
because of uh internet connection issues
we have catherine green licensing
officer
emma richbelt assistant manager food
safety and licensing
david smith legal adviser karen sayer
governance officer
and we also have david price licensing
officer
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence
no apologies received chair
can i now ask you to take a roll call
for the members present
please thank you chair members please
can you reply with good morning or
present when i call out your name
councillor brewster present
councillor penyong
i don't think he's here councillor
flatman
she's also not here councillor geek
present
councillor guthrie present councillor
muller
present councillor autumn
no counsellor phillips
no councillor pratt
councillor pratt are you there
uh yeah sorry um it seems a bit fuzzy i
couldn't i couldn't hear that yes i am
here
thank you councillor stringer president
thank you thank you chair um if you are
getting um problems with
hearing issues can you let us know just
pop your hands up or
um if you can contact um is it your good
self karen or is it
um mandy that will be in the background
so if you do have problems can you
contact mandy for us please
and her phone number is 078-608-29538
i think that's correct i hope any
declarations of interest by councillors
no so
oh councillor stringer
yes just to declare that i am a personal
alcohol license holder
you for that
[Music]
so moving on can we confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on the 7th of august
please
and what i will ask are there any points
of accuracy in the minutes
that need counsellor stringer again
sorry sorry chair that's a historic hand
that's taking ages to
lower okay thank you for that if you'd
load that down
so can i have a proposer and a seconder
for the minutes please councillor muller
yeah i'm happy to propose thank you
chair
and a seconder for those minutes please
i'm happy to second manager thank you
thank you very much thank you for both
of you who got there councillor brewster
did that for us please and so the
governance officer can you take a roll
call vote
on on that issue please thank you
thank you chair members please can you
reply with four against or abstain
counselor brewster four
councillor geek four councillor guthrie
four councillor four
councillor pratt four councillor
stringer
four thank you chair that's carried
and again they will be signed at the
next practicable
opportunity thank you for that so to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the
petition scheme none received chair
thank you so we now have the governance
officer
to report the licensing act statement of
licensing policy
statutory five-year revision so i'll
invite
and it will be emma richbelt who's going
to present this matter for us thank you
emma
thank you chair this is to report back
to the licensing and regulatory
committee
the outcome of a full targeted and
public consultation
which ran between the 20th of august
2020 and the 16th of september 2020
in respect of the statement of licensing
policy for mid-south district council
since november 2005 local licensing
authorities have been responsible for
functions under the licensing act
2003 section 5 of the licensing act 2003
requires that each licensing authority
shall determine and publish
a local statement of licensing policy
relating to the discharge of its
licensing functions under the act
the licensing team revisited the
statement which has been in effect since
january 2016.
this report seeks the approval by the
licensing and regulatory committee
of the revised policy statement attaches
appendix a
for recommendation on default council so
that it may be adopted for publication
and ready to take effect
from the 7th of january 2021
so the recommendation is that the post
consultation draft
statement of licensing policy in respect
of the licensing act 2003 functions
as attached to appendix a be approved
financial implications this is a
statutory function
the licensing team has undertaken the
necessary work within existing resources
and fee structure
in general terms the legislation aims to
secure full cost recovery of
administering licensing act 2003
functions
through fees payable for license
applications and ongoing maintenance
the fee banding system and fee levels
are currently set by central government
via regulation as they have been
unchanged since 2005.
the previous government decided in early
2015 not
to activate the provisions of the police
reform and social responsibility act
2011
section 121 which would have devolved
free setting to local licensing
authorities
this will be the fifth edition of the
council's statement of licensing policy
under the licensing act 2003
the licensing team has the necessary
experience stakeholder contacts and
networking in place
to ensure that a wide and balanced
consultation has taken place
the consultation took place over a
period of four weeks
through various channels and media
adoption of the licensing act 2003
statement of licensing policy is a
function reserve for full
council following the consultation
exercise mid-summit district council did
not receive any responses
therefore no further changes are
required to be made to the draft
statement of licensing policy and this
concludes my summary
thank you for that emma uh do members
have any questions for emma
and you may use the hands up function if
you would
cancel a stringer
thank you chair um just just a bit of
clarity really
uh where it starts in the preamble
uh where the change has been uh we've
got four and a half thousand new
residents
which is about normal but has
mid-suffolk actually grown by 107
hectares
because because it's bigger than it was
last time
oh that's interesting and i i don't know
that the answer to that i mean kay and
catherine did some research to make sure
that all of our
stats are up to date and i'm not quite
sure where the increase
in area came from if i'm honest with you
i don't know whether david or catherine
can help
um we we did do some research um
into the the figures but we can go back
to that
if you if they're not accurate but i'm
we're pretty sure
that they were i i think it's probably a
rounding issue because you probably
rounded down to the nearest thousand
hectares last time and you've actually
got it accurate
either that or someone's filled in
needham lake which i don't think has
happened
no uh thank you for that councillor
stringer can i just
ask emma whether um if you just review
that but whether that's a critical thing
that we
can't present to council we can look at
that and
absolutely we will yes we'll check that
thank you councillor stringer if you
take your hand down now thank you does
anyone else have any other points to
observe
no in that case um
then we can open the item up for debate
counselor muller followed by councillor
stringer
thank you chair um apart from the item
that's just been raised by council
stringer
i'm quite happy with this document no no
licenses
license premises have made any
objections or made any further
amendments
so i'm more than happy to move approval
of this as per the recommendations thank
you chair
thank you for that councillor muller
councillor stringer
yeah i'd be happy to second this just
one proviso and
it's a question uh and it might be one
where we are duplicating policy
but do we need a failure to comply
with government lockdown policy within
this
so that you're not only risking a fine
you're actually
risking losing your license
i think we've discussed this before
about um the covid issue emma can you
give us a response on that
yeah i think we wouldn't want to
incorporate it into a statement of
licensing policy
i mean let's hope that we don't have
covid for the next five years
um that's hopefully a transient matter
it's something which is being dealt with
by the food safety licensing team under
separate legislation
if there was continued failure to comply
with covid requirements
it's very likely that that would be also
a failure to comply with with other
health and safety
food safety and licensing requirements
which could result in a review but i
don't think we need to
necessarily name kobe as a separate
reason for that in the policy
thank you for that emma i know we can
discuss that in the past and andrew if
you want to come back yeah sorry
sorry i didn't mention kovid i said i
said
i actually said government lockdown
government lockdown and covid could be
two different things
understood understood um again i think
it's something which we would um yes i
mean it could be a cause for a review to
be brought
but um you it would need to be one of
the breach of one of the four licensing
objectives
so we would need to look at each case
and its merits and i think
lockdown is a current issue at the
moment yes there could be reasons in the
future to do so but i think we would
deal with it under our existing
legislation that we would use
so with that oh yes count david smith
our legal advisor is going to give us a
comment if you would please david i can
share i
i think the issue is perhaps that um
there is specific legislation relating
to
controls on licensing during the
pandemic so that could be
directly as a consequence of covered 19
or
indirectly as a consequence of lockdown
and what i would advise is that
if there is a conflict between policy
and law then clearly the law would
override
any policy conflict that there might be
but as um emma says there are there is
procedure if need be to review uh in due
course but i would just make that
comment so far as
any potential conflict is concerned i
hope that assists
that's very helpful on that basis
councillor stringer do you wish to
remain as the second or
yes i do that's a very comprehensive
reply and
i suspected that would be the case but
it's handy to cover that off
because we've gotten you know we see in
the media all the time with licensed
premises
you know sometimes pushing the envelope
as it were
right okay then if there's no further
comments
um can i ask um that uh we
go around and that the um committee
officer asks whether we
approve or our vote on the
proposal and uh perhaps you'd just like
to read the recommendation out again for
us
thank you chair recommendation 3.1
that the post consultation draft
statement of licensing policy
in respect of licensing act 2003
functions
as attached at appendix a to the report
be approved
and the recommendation to council 3.2
that the statement of licensing policy
document be adopted
would you like me to carry out the roll
call vote now yes please
if you would thank you chair members
please can you reply with four against
or abstain councillor brewster
councillor brewster sorry i forgot to
unmood
uh four thank you councillor geek
four councillor guthrie four
councillor muller four councillor pratt
paul councillor stringer four
thank you chair that's carried lovely
well there's no other business
uh to discuss or debate so i'll just
thank everybody for their input and the
officers for a very clear report
and answers to the questions thank you
emma and
this will go to the full council thank
you very much indeed mata and the
meeting
closed thank you
you